larry king né en 1933 à new york
son père meurt alors qu'il a 9 ans et il
enfilera les petits boulots pour aider
sa mère à nourrir la famille mais il
rêve de radio et c'est dans les années
50 qu'il se retrouve en floride et
devient homme à tout faire dans une
station locale le départ d'un des
animateurs lui servira de tremplin sa
première émission est diffusée en mai 57
dans les années 60 c'est au tour de la
télé de lui faire de l'oeil mais il sera
arrêté dans sa lancée par des démêlés
judiciaires qui lui font perdre tous ses
contrats un ex collègue l'accusent de
vol qualifié
il est finalement innocentées quelques
mois plus tard mais il lui faudra sept
ans pour rebâtir sa carrière en 1978 et
il commence l'animation d'une émission
de radio nocturne diffusé partout aux
états unis mais c'est une jeune chaîne
d'information cnn à laquelle il se joue
en 1985 qui lui permettra d'atteindre la
gloire durant 25 ans artistes sportifs
président américain et dirigeants
étrangers dont vladimir poutine se
succéderont sur son plateau avec
toujours le même fil conducteur sa très
grande écoute
il avait reçu bill clinton une vingtaine
de fois l'ancien président a souligné
sur twitter le départ de son ami
sa collègue de longue date christiane
amanpour a aussi réagi le nom de larry
king écrite elle est indissociable de
cnn et il a été d'une importance
capitale dans le succès de la chaîne
d'information continue
il avait contracté la coved fin 2020 et
était depuis ce temps spécialisée à los
angelès new marais
à bassorah et si nathalie cloutier radio
canada montréal